good morning John welcome to my Friday
video today with the help of an
anonymous source I'm going to embarrass
you this the new comes in three parts
the first part is embarrassing you so
there is a person in the world who has
some marvelous photoshopping skills who
is running a fake John Green daily booth
account and that fake John Green daily
with account has been updated regularly
for the last like three weeks with
pictures of you in particularly
embarrassing circumstances I don't know
why you're getting this treatment and
I'm not but I'm not complaining so what
are all these hilarious pictures you
asked well there's this one of you
declaring your love for unicorns there's
one of you dressed as Edward Cullen
there's one of you doing a funny dance
with a crowbar there's one of the Poe
bust kissing you and following that
theme there's one where you're Willy and
Willy is you there's one of you finally
admitting that the puff is a wig and one
where you have the superpower of being
able to turn into a bobblehead whenever
you want to of course they're not all
embarrassing some of them are just
ridiculously awesome like the cover of
John Green magazine this picture of John
Green day and of course your own brand
of cereal this advertisement for fat
sandwiches and you doing a happy dance
on the moon I just wanted you to know
about the fik-shun during dailybooth it
has been consistently hilarious for
weeks now and I'm really impressed so if
you all want to go sign up for that it
would probably be a good idea thing too
today's edition of the fake John Green
daily booth had something that had to do
with me which was this fake back cover
of show jokes in which the tracklisting
shows nothing except for versions of
Accio Deathly Hallows and I take that
criticism at face value hilarious but it
reminded me that I haven't really talked
about the fact that I am working on a
second studio album and it is going to
be colossal I haven't finished the exact
tracklist for it yet but it's looking
like it's gonna have at least 15 studio
tracks on it and they're all songs that
I'm really proud of and like I think are
really good and of course you're
entitled to your own opinion on that
several folks and I are working on the
cover design already and there may be a
super secret surprise involved as well
I'm not going to talk about that yet
though because I'm not sure it's gonna
work out there is also a chance that I
will tour with the new album but because
it's coming out fairly soon it's going
to be hard to plan a real tour so I was
hoping folks could send me
email at Hank and John at gmail.com
letting me know if they have any
connections at any venues that are west
of the Rocky Mountains we did the east
side of the country with the tort of
nerdfighting I feel like the west side
of the country needs some lovin and just
so you know when I say venues I don't
know what I mean it's fairly important
that the roofs be able to fit like 150
to 200 people it's very important that
the shows are all aged and it's fairly
important that it's near a big city but
that's pretty much my only requirement
I'm happy to play colleges clubs
libraries bookstores anything so it's
possible but I'm not guaranteeing
anything that I will be doing a little
tour of the western United States along
with the release of my new album I hope
you are as excited about that
possibility as I am the third thing that
I wanted to talk about was the thing
that I'm wearing Hey which is a new
shirt that John and Alan and I are
selling at dftba.com right now I got it
in the mail yesterday and I immediately
put it on I've been wearing it ever
since I immediately put it on and I went
to show the Katherine and she'll to me
it shoots like who sent that to you
don't mess with the Katherine thank you
to Morgan for the awesome design it is
the official won't you be a nerdfighter
like with me shirt as coined by the
marvelous lauren fairweather and covered
by me on my previous album so jokes I
have to say that generally our shirts
don't last very long because we print up
a certain number and then that's it so
if you want to go to dftba.com right now
you can get this but if you wait you
might not be able to I like it I think
it's cute Katherine thought it was cute
too once she figured out it wasn't some
random girl who sent it to me talk about
a great gift so you can get it now dftba
calm and you can get so jokes at the
same time if you don't have it yet
that's never a bad idea to have the
first album before the second one comes
out
hey that is all that is all of my three
parts John I will see you on Sunday